elles sont là elles sont parmi nous
elles peuvent prendre plusieurs formes
toutes différentes dans les moindres
recoins elle se faufile ressemblant à
s'y méprendre à des serpents en
plastique enroulée en bobine elles
s'entassent prennent de la place
mais de quelle façon cela at il commencé
créé pour garder le souvenir du temps
passé enregistré le bonheur revivre des
jours heureux
ces images filmées ont fini par
grignoter le réel pour endiguer la
prolifération des pellicules et
reconquérir leur espace les humains sont
à présent voué à inventer de nouvelles
technologies qui sort est à la fois
réduire en taille ces objets sans
supprimer leur mémoire
ainsi ils ont trouvé une solution la
numérisation
après si on part de zéro notre image et
l'a donc vous pouvez jouer sur la
luminosité
les gamins etc et puis à l'intérieur de
chacun sur les gammes de couleurs les
humains à présent tri scrute dans les
moindres détails ces images et procède à
une sélection minutieuse chaque négatif
est passé sous les ères identifiés et
enregistrés ces pellicules finiront
leurs jours dans les sous sols de
inhospitalier pour les humains où la
température n'excède pas les 8 degrés
celsius
à force de courage et de persévérance
ils reprennent le contrôle sur leur vie
hsc super 8
mais la tâche est colossale à
saint-etienne par exemple certaines
bobines ont presque cent ans et sa
cinémathèque renferme quelques trésors
du cinéma populaire et éducatif
stéphanois pionnière à bien des égards
dans la valorisation de ce patrimoine
elle a mis en accès libre sur ce site
ce cinéma du début du 20e siècle
redécouvert lors de la numérisation
en parcourant ce lieu je me dis que ces
films sont une mine d'or des kilomètres
d'image de notre civilisation passé plus
de deux mille huit cents ouvrages 120
titres de revues de cinéma et 7000
titres de vidéos ils sont stockés un
historien il trouverait aujourd'hui une
richesse infinie d'information et les
archéologues du futur ne seront pas non
plus les et on y trouve de tout du très
connus comme les charlots et buster
keaton à des productions plus discrètes
comme du cinéma rural ou encore des
vidéos de vulgarisation car oui la
vulgarisation qu'on associe beaucoup à
youtube de nos jours n'est pas neuve
présenté comme un nouveau média une
nouvelle manière de diffuser du savoir
la création sur internet et vues comme
une sorte de révolution dans le partage
des connaissances et de la culture
générale mais en réalité cela a toujours
existé et elle saint-etienne ou projet
de ces vidéos depuis 1920 aux écoliers
alors ça ne s'appelait ni youtube nice
c'est pas sorcier met office du cinéma
scolaire et éducateurs du documentaire
éducatif du long métrage récréatif des
débats après projection
en somme un cinéma au service de
l'éducation
les films projetés aux élèves ont pour
fonction principale de les faire rire et
mais l'école est finalement de les aider
à mémoriser leur leçon éducation ign
sport géographie histoire art science et
même campagne anti alcoolisme
tout est abordable est abordé par le
cinéma éducateurs ce type de pédagogie
par l'image est précisément ce que tente
d'ailleurs de remettre sur pied les
enseignants de pete 2018 avec l'aide du
ministère de la culture a été publié une
liste de chaînes youtube propre à être
diffusés en classe en novembre dernier
l'instruction par l'image est né au
sortir de la première guerre mondiale
notamment à saint-etienne et ne s'est
pas arrêté depuis
j'ai donc
me sens 26 26 mais tu sais que ça fait
moderne
un siècle après leur création les images
sont encore capables de raisonner dans
nos esprits les images sont partout les
envahissent la vie c'est certain si bien
qu'elle aurait pu faire sombrer les
humains dans la paranoïa il les aurait
alors sa beauté abandonné mais trop
attachés à leurs reflets ils ont choisi
de les conserver les connaissances et
savoirs des humains enregistrées sur
pellicule ou disque dur empiète leur
espace vital qu'elles soient autrefois
argentique ou maintenant numérique ces
bandes passantes sont aussi la preuve de
l'existence des humains sur la terre
ils ont compris la menace que
représentent les envahisseuses mais
plutôt que de détruire ces oeuvres états
ayant choisi la lutte et chacun d'entre
eux va à présent continuer son travail
sa destinée et la terre continue de
tourner autour de son axe inconsciente
du désastre auquel elle a échappé
[Musique]